we all adults we all agree the Special
Olympics is a good it's a good program
it's great I just feel like the guy who
came up with it had to be like a real
risk
taker some guy in a board meeting like I
got an idea we should be racing these
[__] like what did you say
[__] town over said they had the
fastest
ones say we settle it you know I'm not
making fun of the Olympians the concept
is wild it's a wild like if your best
friend invented the Special Olympics and
told you about it first you'd be like
don't ever tell anybody that
who the [__] are we going to tell that
to what are you doing
poal you can't do the cool moves you see
in porn just do regular you ever try
them you ever think you can you ever try
like come in a girl's face they're a lot
less receptive in real life that whole
process is a [__] nightmare dude it's
a disaster it's just you the girl he
loves down there you've been begging her
for 3 months to try this finally she's
like yeah you can do it you're like yes
it's going to be just like the videos I
watch every day that's my favorite part
now you get to do it you think it's
going to be awesome it's not it's just
you up there alone it's
cold she's being nice she's like are you
okay now you can feel it you're like all
right here it comes this is going to be
awesome she's going to love this as soon
as it hits him they freeze and then once
it's on them they like don't know how to
move you know what I mean like you ever
put like socks on a cat
or and then you feel bad cuz the comes
out of you and you realize what you've
done feel terrible you got to [__]
pick her up off the ground it's like the
same energy use like when a toddler
Falls come here get up you're all right
you're all right you're all right we'll
never do it again
asy I've heard astrology and belly
button
rings I feel like those go hand girls
still yeah they do the girls are you
guys still getting belly button rings I
don't know I haven't [__] a [__]
lately I know I said [__] there a
couple times my bad on
that I'm not trying to give myself a
pass on being able to use that word but
I will say I don't know if you can tell
by looking at me I do have family
members with Down Syndrome it almost got
me
up I dodged it but it nicked me it
nicked me bit of a day Walker
myself my uncle Danny sneaks grilled
cheese sandwiches into the restaurants
just in case they don't serve grilled
cheese sandwiches we don't know where
he's getting these [__] things it's
the best it's the best you'll be out to
dinner with him you look across the
table you see him sneaking at grilled
cheese
just yeah yo where'd you get that chei
[Music]
Danny his dad's with him he's like that
[__] he's been making him at night I
know he
is I'm not making him at night
dad then he'll look at you and be like
I'm making him at night I think my
favorite part of the year was I uh I got
to watch my dad watch the news he's a
Fox News guy Fox News dad that's a good
[__] dad can you imagine if you had a
[__] MSNBC dad some guy every night
at dinner like we need to start focusing
on renewable energy like ew dude I
didn't know Dad was gay talking to me
about solar panels like a [__] lady
he might D her straight as hell dude we
[__] hate the environment that's how
straight we are all we talk about is
eating [__] and fracking like every Fox
News dad my dad watches Fox every night
until he can't they watch every night
until they get so angry they have to go
to bed my dad watch for like 2 hours and
then out of nowhere he'll just stand up
and be like [__] Mr Potato Heads
trans I'm going to bed this world's
going to hell Fox News is basically
black church for old white dudes you
know what I mean like literally
everything they say my dad just sits
like
mhm yes preach Tucker you watch while I
gets hit with the Holy Spirit while he's
watching it the Holy Ghost visits him
he's just like oh Lord build a wall can
I get a wall white people used to be
cool in America the height of white
people being cool was us going we like
that was as cool as we got we're like
see and then the day white people sto
being cool it was Jackie Robinson's
first game you can look it up dude you
can find it you can find the radio call
from that game online you can hear the
exact moment white people stopped being
cool you can hear the announcers they
still got there like man going to
Chicago with the white socks Tak on the
Brooklyn Dodgers we all had cool white
nicknames like up at the mound is old
curlyy he's a 47-year-old alcoholic he's
the greatest athlete alive runs a 6C 40
yard dash fastest man alive they say
then it happened dude and Jackie came up
to the plate you can hear the announcers
like coming up to the plate is Young
codb from Brooklyn no way he can hit
Curly's pitch Here Comes the pig [__]
home run all right Jackie hit the ball
so knocked that voice out of all the
whites not one of us has talk like that
since dud one swing of the bat we're
like all right yeah that was pretty good
that was good it's time for us to focus
on computers autistic kids they're like
cats little skittish you're not sure if
they like you at
all down syndrome or
dogs they're the dogs dude you get home
you get home from somewhere they're like
where the [__] have you been dude I got
so much to show you this is going to be
the best
day tell ask a Down Syndrome kid do you
want to go for a walk like yeah yeah
yeah yeah like throw a
ball throw a ball I'll get on Twitter
and the first tweet I see will be
someone from back home that's just like
[__] Colin Kaepernick better stand up
like this tweet if you support the
police share it if you're not gay
[__]
here and then the next post is just one
of my new woke white friends that's just
like I'm not racist that's it every day
for the last year just a different white
person popping up like look at me look
at this article I shared to my Instagram
story I'm not racist right like all
right you sure so I don't know if you
know this like being racist isn't like a
yes or no thing you know what I mean
it's not like you have it or you don't
have it like being racist is more it's
like being hungry you know it's like
yeah you're not right now
it's like yeah you're not hungry right
now but a cheeseburger could cut you off
on the
highway we hungry all
day the cheeseburger is Jewish in that
joke no okay I do this thing it's not a
good thing but whenever I'm dating a
girl I always talk [__] on her ex's it's
not a good look women don't respect it
kind of makes me look like a [__] I
like it I I can't stop doing and
normally it's easy normally it's like
what's your ex do he's a [__]
substitute teacher it's weird he wants
to hang out with kids like that bad you
know like this one's tough this is a
tough X to make fun of just when I'm
walking around the apartment all day
just [__] Navy
Seals they're kind of [__] if you
really think about it you know what I
mean like using night vision sneaking up
on guys that's a [__] coward's way to
fight dude you know who's actually Brave
Al-Qaeda that takes courage and bravery
in pajamas throwing rocks at
tanks hero [__] dude just you and your
boys going out in flipflops you're all
going to get [__] up for real though
it was my favorite speech I've ever seen
a president give it is the night the
United States killed the leader of Isis
Trump comes out of the Situation Room at
like midnight and gives a press
conference like he's giving a post game
NBA just killed a guy press conference
he was Abu bakar outbag daddy is dead he
died like a dog and
I'm I didn't change one word of that
that's what he opened with and then he
did 40 minutes the speech is 40 minutes
for no reason it wasn't a prepared
speech he freestyled 40 straight not
even a speech just mean [__] talk for 40
the meanest [__] talk you've ever heard
in front of the whole world
Abu we could hear him crying I said Abu
don't cry Abu let me tell you something
Abu cried he cried quite a bit I
wouldn't have
cried Cry Baby Back daddy that's what we
were all calling
like as big as racism is in America
football there's a Disney movie Remember
the Titans dedicated to what I just told
you the whole point of that dude that
was one high school football season
Remember the Titans was like it was
eight weeks that whole town went from
like centuries of like don't let them in
our school to just like oh [__] the high
school team's
4-0 those are my
brothers the point I'm trying to make is
if you want to get rights in America you
just got to put together a good football
team you know what I mean if the
transgenders got together and put
together just a [__] hard nose run it
down your throat ball Club if the trans
just three yards in a cloud of dust of
transgenders if the trans if the trans
Community could just somehow upset
Alabama everybody down there tomorrow
would be like those are some tough
[__]
actually anytime I go to another country
as soon as I get out of the airport and
start like driving around I'm just like
dude this is your [__] country dude
other countries suck America is number
one dude it's not even it's official
I've been to like three other countries
it's official other countries hate it
too they hate that we're number one you
ever tell them you ever go to another
country and tell them we're number one
swim up to like a pool bar
just you know we're number one they hate
it dude they try to bring up [__] to
bring us down like what about all the
mass shootings you guys have all the
time it's like at least we're not
gay you know there's really not a good
comeback to that cuz it's a pretty
serious problem and we're the only
country doing that we're not making any
adjustments n what are we going to give
up our guns like a bunch of [__] gay
guys yeah right dude no we're just going
to have shootings all the
time yeah Australian accent is one of
those accents that's funny every single
time you could be in the middle of a
[__] tragedy if you heard an
Australian accent you'd still be like
like if there was like an Australian guy
in the office on 9/11 I was like oh [__]
look out like oh no there's another one
get
downn a [__] it's hot up here you're
going to have to jump out
[Music]
no never mind I was thinking about the
first time like Congress had to come up
with age of
consent that had to be like the powdered
wigs and stuff that had to be a rough
day for the
fellas it's like some guy coming up
first like from Rhode Island 12 and's
like ew ew no
dude I don't know why do I have to go
first on this one it's like the hardest
one to go first
on sexually I have I have to follow a
[__] Navy SEAL they never quit until
the job's done dude that's their whole
thing I quit a lot all right the job's
done when I'm tired which is usually
pretty early into the mission my arms
start shaking pretty early they give out
next thing you know we're having belly
to belly missionary she hunched over
breathing in her ear like a pug for 5
minutes just coughing coughing during
sex is funny
just you guys know belly to belly
missionary dude don't [__] I saw this
crowd dude I see you boy loud of belly
belly tonight dude this guy's hunched
over
just you don't even think about that
noise you're making in that poor woman's
ear every woman in this room has heard
that noise you've never thought the only
way I can describe it is like you ever
lay down and a dog starts sniffing your
ear that's what it sounds like every
[Music]
just
the gayer the Army the scarier forever
dude throughout history think of any
army throughout history imagine them gay
gay Nazis just when you thought those
guys couldn't look any sharper they gay
Vikings gay Vikings dude you're just
some villager looking out on the
shoreline see a bunch of Viking
longships coming you're like oh no it's
the Vikings they're going to rape our
wives and daughters then they pull up
their [__] rainbow flag on their boat
just like oh
[__] oh that's way worse my roommate his
girlfriend played college volleyball so
I'm very excited to like [__] on
volleyball whenever I can so I get in
there and I was like yo volleyball is
[__] that's a weird culture get them
[__] shorts get them gym shorts dude
the shorts they're wearing is gross and
she was like no we need those shorts for
Speed on the court and I was like uh I I
know that's not true I watched the
NBA none of you are moving as fast f is
like a ref and those guys are wearing
like slacks dress shoes for some reason
she was like no we need those shorts the
tight shorts they're essential she
compared them to like a helmet in
football I was like I know they're not
essential because I Googled the uh the
Special Olympics volleyball
team all of a sudden those shorts
weren't so essential for
them what's that about how baggy do you
think they're they look like the [__]
N1 mixtape out there offensively baggy
is how I would describe all of their
attires I'm not discounting the fact
it's hard for families it is I've
witnessed it firsthand it's difficult
it's very scary at first then you
quickly realize that's easily the only
good family member we have that's the
only good person I know they're the Bros
dude they're the perfect bro they love
two things dude they love John Cena
across the board dude you see one of
these dudes out in public hit them with
a they're going to give it back they
love them and they love
tits dudes with Down Syndrome love tits
and it's a very uncomfortable Truth for
a lot of people and I'm not sure why tit
rule John Cena rules there kind of the
two coolest things this joke's probably
not going to make it but here all right
here this one out dudes with Down
Syndrome love women so much I've never
been a believer of being gay is a choice
but I will say every dude I know that
can't think [__] loves
[__] all right I guess it's a
keeper I'm not a republican yet but I
will say I don't care if they arrest him
if he loses the primary let him debate
dude if he gets arrested Hannibal
elector him out to the [__] here's my
idea final debate of the year have one
Republican candidate one Democrat you're
like all right fellas surprise third
guest tonight [__] Stone Cold music
the glass shatters he walks out they're
both gay I think it is actually
important to see how the candidates
handle that type of pressure of debating
with Trump every debate he just bullied
whoever was up there the only one who
did pretty good in the debates against
him was Biden just cuz he had no [__]
idea what was being said which actually
helped him that worked out for him cuz
Trump's whole thing is he tries to get
in the other guy's head can't get in
Joe's head Jo Joe's not in there good
luck dude Biden is Trump's cryptonite in
a debate Trump tries to drag the other
guy into like a shitalking contest he
can't get Biden every debate he's trying
so hard and Biden's
just he tries he just you're a loser
your son did crack Biden's just what
damn dude that's actually a pretty good
comeback you might win this thing every
year Hooters would sponsor R1 basketball
tournament all right so every year
Hooters would bring like three or four
waitresses and they would present like a
big cardboard check donation to the
Special Olympics as soon as the girls
entered the gym the game changed
entirely dude it went from like hugs and
sportsmanship to just like dudes got
competi like very competitive [__]
ripping down rebounds just hitting
layups
and and then at the end of the game
there'd be a hug line between the
waitresses and the players and yeah that
went about exactly exactly how you would
imagine that one we' to break out the
[__] jaws of life dude my boys a ragd
dooll in those young
slots and I'm not knocking the the
players they were totally in the right
the girls were hot The Waitresses like
every year I would sneak into the hug
line
myself that's the thing about these
countries I just in England Scotland
Ireland Australia no black people and I
know what you're thinking
no no you need black people you need
black people to keep the whites in check
the last thing you want is a whole
island of whites that think they're the
coolest people on Earth it's a disaster
that's how you end up with Conor
McGregor is walking around
like it's like shut up dude the foreign
whites are out of control American
whites we're
humble we know we're not the coolest
guys around it's the foreign whites dude
yeah is there yes prach brother yeah for
real though there's a reason every good
NBA player that's white is from another
country the audacity to think you could
play in that League dude the [__]
arrogance every white dude in America
saw a black kid dunk in like 8ighth
grade and was just like oh all
right there goes that
dream we just set picks for the next
four
years just box out hard as
hell you ever see an old lady fall like
my Grandma fell she was trying to get
the hose from behind her house and she
fell behind a bush should I act it out
like
if you want but it looked like the wild
the well this is going distract me I
think now that you're doing it I was
like it looked
like uh but yeah she fell and then her
feet were just sticking out from a bush
and she laid there for like 2 hours it
was the summer whoa wait
she she wizard of Austin or she was no
like just her feet were sticking out
from under a bush in her backyard and
then a neighbor's kid found her which is
very funny cuz if you don't have Life
Alert and you're old you just have to
yell but it's very faint if you're older
lay there be like
help isn't that
funny you guys don't think it's funny to
have to lay there I don't know if you
know this the war in the Middle East is
just on the internet the whole [__]
every dude out there on both sides was
wearing GoPros the entire time like you
can watch it we watched like three hours
of the war in Iraq and after the first
hour I found myself starting to cheer
not cheer but
like relate I felt like I could relate
more to the monkey bars guys you know
what I mean they were a little more my
speed you ever wonder how you would do
out there watch those guys those are
just normal [__] dudes second shots
are fired there's no game plan there oh
[__] very relatable guns jamming try to
fire a rocket it goes straight [__]
backwards they're very they look like me
trying to fire a gun their feet move
when they
shoot very relatable
they also never won they never they got
[__] up every single time bad they
would blow up like one truck every 5
months they'd be just as surprised as
everybody [__] finally worked out you
could hear in their voice someone blow
up they'd be like oh H like yeah dude
that's a human reaction that's relatable
that's what I would do if I saw a
[__] explosion I go
oh that's human you ever watch us kill
people I can't relate to that at all
there's some Blackhawk helicopter with
night vision mows down like 40 people
pilot gets on he just goes clear just F
just flies away it's like yo that's a
psycho that guy didn't give a [__] about
that